I think there's two different types of
readers people who read books right
there is the accidental reader and then
there's the intentional reader what's
the accidental reader accidental reader
is somebody that just says hey I
accidentally found this book or somebody
told me about it so I'm reading it
versus the intentional is graduated the
accidental mindset and the intentional
is saying how do I pick and choose which
books for me to read as an entrepreneur
and I'm going to talk about that with
you here today on how you should process
which book for you to read next we can
save a lot of time because as a business
owner as an entrepreneur your time is
very valuable you've got to make sure
you protect your time as much as
possible and there's nothing worse than
reading a book that's a terrible book so
let's go through the system together
first of all for me there are four
reasons why we read books one is purely
entertainment so this could be you'll
like to read certain fiction or whatever
simply because of entertainment another
one is inspiration I like to read
biographies because they inspire me oh
my gosh when I read the story of Steve
Jobs or a Benjamin Franklin or Elon Musk
or Nikola Tesla or if I read I just got
so inspired when I read it or it's how
to how to raise money how to master the
art of selling how to dot how to tell a
story how to all that stuff is how to to
get steps and then the last one is
knowledge knowledge give me what
philosophy knowledge could be you know
the specific details about health on how
to cut your body fat because you read
all these different diets I want to be
knowledgeable in my diet on how to
become more healthy that's the knowledge
part right so there's four different
types of books that we read
entertainment inspiration how to
acknowledge now this complete opposite
side is how I just pick and choose my
books to read one is an author what do I
mean by an author it's similar to an
actor if I see Matthew McConaughey in a
movie I'm gonna watch that movie if I
see Rachel McAdams in a movie I'm gonna
watch that movie if I see Denzel Will
Smith there's a list of actors that if I
see them in a movie I am most likely
going to go watch that movie same exact
thing with a book if Ann
Robert Greene writes a book I'm the
first one reading the Roberts a good
friend of mine he's written 40 laws of
power 33 strategies of war art of
seduction mastery 58 life he writes a
book I'm the first one that's reading it
because I follow the author so you may
read a book simply because you enjoy the
author second one maybe reviews you know
you got certain books that get Raven
reviews so you're like wait a minute why
like the others I read a book I'm like
this the reviews are just astounding
about this book here I bought the book
simply because of the reviews the other
thing may be subject this is very very
important to keep amount about subjects
so eventually you as a reader this is my
suggestion to you as a reader is to read
intentionally based on subjects meaning
you are not a good leader you want to
learn how to become a leader going Merce
yourself on all the best leadership
books you are not a very good salesman
you want to become a better salesman go
study all the sales books out there I
get a lot of message from people telling
me Pat can you make a top 10
recommendation for sales books I'm
thinking about that I'll get back to you
guys I know what I'm going to do that
episode or not all on sales you want to
become a very good entrepreneur go read
everything on entrepreneurship go read
everything on marketing pick a topic
pick a skill obsess about learning about
that topic I have a friend of mine that
he wants to study real estate
development and real estate investing
he's reading everything on that that's
how it ought to be social media read
everything on social media instead of
going all over the place scatter mind
right so subject and a fourth one for me
is the credibility of the recommender
there is there is nothing more annoying
to me that when somebody gives me book
and says hey I've never read this book
but I think you'll like it that's kind
of offensive and we tell you why it's
kind of offensive
can you imagine recommending a movie
that you've never seen
hey go watch this movie I've never seen
it but go waste your two hours of your
life and I'll tell me if it's good it's
kind of offensive to me right I mean I
like to recommend a book to somebody and
say I read this book here's what I got
out of it and based on what you're
asking I think this is a very good book
for you that shows respect on when you
recommend
the book to somebody so credibility of a
recommender so many times you may read a
book because let's just say you have a
mentor you have somebody that's your
advisor your mentor and they may
recommend the book to you for you to
read you better believe if my mentor
recommends a book for me to read and
it's my mentor and they've read the book
I am NOT even hesitating about reading
this book that book is done now I don't
have a lot of mentors have a handful of
mentors alive a live mentor a lot of
dead mentors but I've had full of
mentors that have influence over me if
staked on the side you got to read this
book like this the book is done why that
person sees an area in my life that
either needs inspiration or needs
improvement or needs clarity that's
willing to take the time to recommend me
to read the book I'm not hesitating
because my advisors and my mentors are
more valuable to me than any million
dollar checking account they could have
a ten million dollar checking account so
if they're to recommend anything to me I
will go out there and make sure I move
on it so the same thing here I get
people that message me and say hey Pat I
want you to be my mentor really yes read
these two books 25 lots were doing the
impossible and life of an entrepreneur
then I'll mention Don I don't want to
read books I just want you to mentor me
then you don't understand the subject of
mentoring you want lazy way of becoming
wealthy but you don't want the hard work
way of you having to click as you going
through this and all of a sudden you get
clarity about a certain thing you need
to do and so credibility of a
recommender so this is how I suggest to
pick books to read don't just go out
there and wing it generally when a new
person becomes an entrepreneur you
typically read Rich Dad Poor Dad or you
start off with how to win friends and
influence people or laws of success or
not laws of success Think and Grow Rich
or there's a certain group of books that
everybody reads and then they get stuck
and that typically happens after about
reading 20 30 40 books once you've read
the 40 books follow this system here and
in my suggestion I don't waste a lot of
my time with entertainment I don't waste
a lot of my time with entertainment my
life as my life started getting busier
and busier and busier and busier and
busier I minimize things that were
wasting my time if I
the book and entertainment and it takes
me six hours to read this book you just
wasted six hours of my life unless if
it's entertainment to inspire my
imagination then I'm game for that but
if it's entertainment romance novel what
am I trying to inspire my having that
terrible of a personal marriage or
relationship that I need inspiration to
read this I don't need that I'm okay
with that I'll figure out ways to
inspire myself then using that
entertainment part so you hopefully this
year set up on people ask Pat how do you
choose your books and what book should I
read this is the formatting I use when
choosing books because eventually one
ought to go from being an accidental
reader to an intentional reader to make
sure your subjects you're reading is
progressing in the in the area of your
business as a CEO as a leader as an
entrepreneur you're constantly advancing
to the next level so with that being
said with that being said if you're
watching this video on a complete
different website you can always come
back to Patrick beta be calm boom and
then throw me the SUBSCRIBE pillow as
well we need your help to help us get
two hundred thousand subs if you have
not subscribed to this channel yet the
best channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs click on the bottom here
button here on the bottom and subscribe
to this channel Michelangelo can you
catch it good catch buddy proud of them
so with that being said thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
you